So here's an example that should make it intuitively clear the clustering
sometimes make sense.
So take Katie and me, we both have a movie collection at home.
And just imagine that both of us look at each other's movies, and all movies,
and Katie gets to rank them from really, really bad to great.
And I to get to rank the same movies from bad to great.
Now it so turns out that Katie and I have very different tastes.
Maybe some movies that I love, like all my James Bond movies, but
Katie doesn't like as much.
And there's others or these chick flicks, that Katie loves, and I don't.
So somewhat exaggerated.
It mind end up, that our movies fall into different classes,
depending on who likes which movies.
So say, say you're Netflix, and
and you look at both my queue and Katie's queue, and you graph it like that.
Then you can conclude, wow, there's two different classes of movies.
Without knowing anything else about movies,
you would say, here's class A and class B.
And they're very different in characteristics.
And the reason why Netflix might want to know this is next time Katie comes in,
you want to kind of propose a movie that fits into class B and on to class A.
Otherwise, she's very unlikely to watch this movie.
And conversely, for me, you want a reach into class A versus class B.
In fact, if you were to look at those movies,
you might find that old style westerns are right over here.
And modern chick flicks might be sitting over here.
Who knows?
But that's an example of clustering.
Because here, there's no target labels given.
Then they move down for you if class A and B existed.
But after looking at the data, you could,
through clustering, deduce as two different classes, and you could even look
at the movie titles to understand what these classes are all about.